we're here with the official cyborg
character breakdown from injustice to
now this was taken from nether realms
live stream but considering the game
comes out this Tuesday May 16th go ahead
and hit that subscribe button to keep up
with all of our injustice - coverage
all right so cyborg has actually unlike
Aquaman Aquaman was really really good
before so he kind of plays similar
cyborg has gone through a ton of changes
he is still a zoning powerhouse he's
still projectile based but we've given
him a few tricks number one he has a new
combo this is two three and it'll knock
you far away it's a very fast mid and
it's actually neutral on blocks so it's
totally safe meaning to those who don't
know a block made you guys cyborg and
Robin will both be able to attack at the
same time like cyborg is not just
sitting there open for an attack it's so
very good recovery essential if it's
block he still finds fine and the
opponent's fun and you're just kind of
your friend literally knew there's no
friends in combat you're true here I've
met them phone so cyborg up close was
never really that powerful and this is
just a fun little tool that you can use
right he also has a new angle his
fireballs are back but he can now do an
upwards one and you can hold it just
like the other one you can meter burn
it'll do - and his air fireballs back
and he actually has from air downwards
farm and again he could meet a grant so
cyber was a character that really kept
you out and just shipped you out and
didn't let you come in and preyed on
your mistakes and now he has even more
options okay and you can cancel out of
this keep the opponent guessing you can
hold it let it go you can hold that you
could Robin has to hold another change
to boost this offense little this
guesses power fist in the original in
the meter burn just knocked you down it
is now actually combo start
so that includes this table mobility
[Music]
that's a combo
yeah and it's techno tackles back that's
now invisible makeup attack so if he's
getting you know when the opponent
finally does get it and they get their
offense going that's an admissible rule
that he can use to try to get out of
trouble and his missiles are back they
now hit mid and you can still do close
medium or far and his vacuums back which
he can do in the air and you can sharp
it and that's just a safe room that you
can cancel into and it'll push the
opponent away and then you can go back
to your fireballs got it so the biggest
change those to his character power it's
been completely redone the heal is gone
and he now uses mother box technology so
he has multiple versions can put it out
and then this drone will fly and the
neat thing is you can actually fully
move once you release it so you can do
this and then while it's out you could
be shooting fireballs and the whole
screen is cover yep you can also do a
little rumba floor drone which is
slow-moving drone that will go across
the screen hits it pops up so you can do
strategies like zoning zoning you put
the rumba out and then you can actually
advance you can go with the opponent has
to block that they have to be looking
out for that he plays his game
and if you're not paying attention
they're going to get launched and he's
free to do all of his attacks there is
quite a long cooldown but they're very
very powerful that you not going on hit
they pop the opponent up they absolutely
control the screen it really enhances
his screen control but she was already
really good at let's say you're really
close to Robin you're really close to
Rocking and you don't want to be there
anymore you don't want to be how do you
get out
he's grapple whatever we thought about
so thanks for reminding him his grapple
is back I like had to I had to give it
to you in riddle
like how would you do as a new throw
Chumlee using his rap oh yeah awesome so
you want to show super yeah cool hey my
favorite part is how he destroys the
parademon with the beam you have look
closely so essentially in a nutshell
it's the same sideboard from part one
but he's a little bit alarm better up
close a little bit her combos a couple
new strings and he's even better from
afar so basically we took a character
that had one area that excelled in
expand a little bit and made him excel
even further than that so he's in a
really good place in this game I think
cyborg fans are gonna be really happy
awesome
shall we show some loadout how about
some low hats do it I saw your load
after you chose earlier and the color
your color schemes are pretty good I
like it
ooh alright so for this one I wanted to
go with mobility maybe you're playing a
match where cyborgs zoning is just not
that effective you actually want to get
it or maybe you just like playing Yolo
cyborg with a new combo opportunities
ready so I get modes ability one the
first one is an air charge you will
actually in the air anytime you can do
it you'll go in
and this has a really neat meter because
this move is unsafe and it's kind of
high risk low reward but you can make it
safe I mean averting it by actually
crackling forward or you can choose to
grapple away so that's just another move
you can use to enhances air mobility and
then another big big one is he gets a
boom to teleport it's super fast really
good recovery so you know you could even
use his drone and then teleport in they
have to block the drone he goes for his
throw mix-ups right and he could do this
back or next to the opponent
so this completely changes the wayside
workplace so now there's a very mobile
side very very mobile software and he
retains you know all of this projects on
special moves so now he can get in and
you can keep the opponent out dodging
one more load out ooh
that's cool now this ability I gave I
really really love this is an absolute
game changer this actually replaces his
character power with all on arm now if
you were familiar with Lex Luthor in the
original injustice it's very similar
once you put this on he can charge it up
to three levels and then he walks around
and while he's glowing he has on and he
is free to do any of his moves in it if
you absorbs an attack he can just
recover and then start going in so
that's incredibly effective so let's say
you're fighting another zoner you know
you can turn this on and you can afford
to cheap trades he can go get his zoning
going get the lively because these
projectiles do a lot of damage or let's
say it's a matchup where you can't
really you can't really zone you have to
go in you could put this in then go in
and there's all kind of crazy strategy
you could intentionally take hits and
then punish the recovery some moves that
are punishable on a be safe because of
the armor and it all depends on how long
you charge it and you can actually - out
of it if you just want to real quick go
to level 1 so this is an enormously
powerful character the trade-off of
courses you do lose the mother box
powers right but girls are power he has
several more that we're not going to
burn and save for a next week that I
can't wait save for another day another
game awesome so thank you Steve yeah
that was cyborg that was cyborg Aquaman
awesome so we don't have anybody here
right now to play so you entice matches
I'll play some angeles play some matches